[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 el coronavirus ha hundido la economía
mundial en una crisis sin precedentes
llevamos seis meses de pandemia y parece
que las cosas al menos en el corto o
medio plazo no se van a arreglar los
economistas prevén una caída del pib del
4,5 por ciento para este 2020 según la
ocde la organización para la cooperación
y desarrollo económico y hoy recibimos
en escala en parís a la asesora de la
economista jefe de este organismo aída
caldera muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros hola buenos días encantada
bueno acaban de publicar un informe que
se llama coronavirus vivir en la
incertidumbre con previsiones para los
países del g20 cuando leemos
incertidumbre en economía no anuncia
nada bueno no es algo bastante negativo
efectivamente en estos momentos estamos
en una situación de mucha incertidumbre
estamos pasando por una pandemia un
virus del que todavía no sabemos muchas
cosas está teniendo un impacto muy
importante sobre la economía
sobre el día a día de las personas el
desempleo ha aumentado la gente tiene
miedo a salir consumir y eso no es bueno
porque afecta a las empresas contratan
menos invierten menos y producen menos y
cierran empresas además exactamente
bueno en este informe se barajan dos
escenarios uno más optimista en el que
hay un control del virus y una
reactivación de la economía y otro más
pesimista en el que bueno pues no se
frenan los contagios se aplican más
medidas restrictivas y por lo tanto se
retrasaría esa recuperación económica
este viernes por ejemplo israel vuelve a
confinar a la población por tres semanas
en cualquier caso hablan de unos 18
meses no hasta principios del 2022 para
que esa economía vuelva a funcionar
vuelva vuelva a andar podrá aguantar la
economía mundial 18 meses de
incertidumbre podría aguantar bueno es
cierto que la situación económica global
no es buena en nuestro estudio como
como ha dicho a corto plazo para este
año vemos que todas las economías del
g20 van a tener un crecimiento negativo
con caídas muy importantes de la
producción del producto interior bruto y
del nivel de 4.5 global esto es una
situación que no ha pasado en la
historia reciente nos tenemos que ir
hacia la guerra la segunda guerra
mundial para ver caídas del pib tan
importante no es una situación mala el
año que viene las cosas van a ser un
poco mejor ya empezamos a ver
crecimientos positivos en todos los
países del g20 para los que hacemos
proyecciones pero aún así la situación
va a ser complicada va a llevar un
tiempo volver a las tasas de crecimiento
que teníamos antes de la pandemia y en
muchos casos se van a perder un
crecimiento del pib equivalente a 4 o 5
años entonces el impacto es es muy
grande muy importante
hablan de 18 meses hablan que
seguramente ya a principios del 2022 a
pesar de que se vaya creciendo un
poquito el año que viene ya a partir de
2022 como que las economías
van a estabilizarse más van a crecer más
y hablan de la vacuna finalmente que
estaría lo mejor disponible a finales
del 2021 o principios 2022 aún no se
sabe pero finalmente la economía mundial
depende de esa vacuna efectivamente
nosotros en nuestra en nuestro análisis
en nuestras hipótesis tenemos en cuenta
que la vacuna aparecerá bueno se
descubrirá hasta a finales estará
disponible a finales del 21 entonces es
muy importante que una vez que esa
vacuna esté disponible se distribuya a
toda la población lo antes posible y que
empiece la preparación ahora la
preparación para adquirir esa vacuna
para poder tener canales de distribución
y que lleguen a todos los países pero
además de la vacuna es importante
respetar las medidas sanitarias que es
lo que hemos estado diciendo durante
mucho tiempo que es identificar a los
casos
y hacer seguimiento y aislamiento de las
personas que están testeando positivas
así con unas medidas menos restrictivas
podemos evitar confinamientos globales
como hemos tenido más generalizados como
hemos tenido en la primavera que tiene
un impacto mayor sobre la economía
entonces es muy importante las medidas
sanitarias y todos los tenemos que
respetar y de eso dependerá que la
economía funcional bueno a nivel global
lo hemos visto es el porcentaje 4,5 de
caída del pib 4.1 para el g20 pero hay
casos en los que esa caída es tremenda
no mucho más preocupante tal vez como
méxico - 10% argentina donde se ha hecho
el confinamiento más largo en el mundo
prácticamente -11% y brasil que es la
mayor economía del continente
latinoamericano 6,5 por ciento cuáles
son las causas de esta situación de
estos porcentajes y las consecuencias no
es cierto que en américa latina la
pandemia está teniendo un impacto muy
importante mayor que en otras
las economías o regiones del mundo
mencionaba méxico y argentina en ambos
casos hemos revisado a la baja nuestras
proyecciones de crecimiento respecto a
lo que pensábamos en junio y se debe más
que nada que el virus todavía está muy
prevalente y que además los
confinamientos han durado más tiempo de
lo que pensábamos pero aparte de estos
casos específicos de estos dos países la
situación en américa latina es especial
tiene retos particulares para empezar
los sistemas de salud no están tan bien
preparados como en otros países quizás
más avanzados los sistemas de protección
de desempleo son menos robustos y
asimismo hay mucha mayor informalidad lo
que hace más difícil proteger a la gente
proteger los ingresos y también tienen
menos menos amplitud de gasto pueden
gastar menos porque tienen menos en
menos impuestos y recolecta menos dinero
a través de los impuestos y deudas más
elevadas entonces a todo esto hace que
les resulte más complicado
luchar contra el virus y la recuperación
será mañana filtración va a ser más
difícil
valora los planes de recuperación que se
han dado por ejemplo en europa en
francia ustedes desde desde la cdeee
recomiendan que se fomenten la creación
de empleo y una creación de empleo con
una transición ecológica no se está
cumpliendo esto con los planes que se
está viendo por ejemplo en europa o
concretamente en francia como decía esta
es una crisis que en realidad es sin
precedentes y nosotros creemos que los
gobiernos y los bancos centrales han
reaccionado bien han reaccionado
rápidamente y masivamente han han
inyectado mucho dinero en las economías
y eso haya permitido que el impacto del
virus haya sido menor que si no hubiera
habido todas estas medidas de contención
pero son suficientes hay que ir más
lejos en estos momentos de momento ha
sido suficiente pero hay que mantenerlas
hay que mantener este gasto por parte de
los gobiernos hay que mantener las tasas
de interés bajas por parte de los bancos
centrales para que el crédito fluya a la
gente a las empresas y no se vea esa
cascada de bancarrotas de las que
hablábamos antes en concreto en el caso
de europa que era una pregunta que hacía
yo creo que el plan el plan de relance o
de reconstrucción europea es un paso muy
importante por una vez
europa ha ido hacia adelante y ha puesto
sobre la mesa mucho dinero a pesar de
que países eran reticentes nuevamente en
holanda exactamente y ahora lo
importante es que ese dinero se gaste
bien se gaste en inversiones que vayan a
tener réditos a largo plazo y también
que ataje en problemas que algunas
economías europeas ya tenían antes de la
pandemia como por ejemplo en el caso de
españa o italia la productividad es baja
hay problemas en el mercado laboral hay
que mejorar la calidad de la educación
entonces ese dinero hay que pasarlo bien
gastarlo para que haya un crecimiento
robusto y además inclusivo y ayudar a
aquellos que están perdiendo más de la
crisis escuchando la veo como si en
pocos años hubiera habido un cambio de
paradigma porque ahora se está
fomentando el gasto público pero hace
unos años en la palabra el término que
imperaba en el mundo era la austeridad y
esta pandemia ha puesto de relieve
muchos aspectos
hablaba de los sistemas de salud se ha
puesto de relieve la infrafinanciación
de los hospitales en francia hubo por
ejemplo muchas manifestaciones para
pedir más medios en españa también para
reclamar más dinero más contrataciones
durante años se quedó sin respuesta ese
reclamo del sector y las medidas de
austeridad tomadas a partir de la crisis
del 2008 y que tuvieron como
consecuencia recortes en sanidad
recortes en educación serían
responsables en parte de la situación
actual en la que muchos hospitales se
han visto completamente desbordados por
esta crisis por esta crisis provocada
por el virus es responsable la
austeridad de lo que pasa en parte ahora
es lo que hemos visto es que durante la
crisis financiera la contención del
gasto público lo que llamamos de
austeridad empezó demasiado pronto
a partir del 2011 tanto en europa como
en eeuu se empezó a reducir ese gasto y
eso hizo que la recuperación fuera más
lenta entonces en estos momentos nuestro
mensaje es no es el momento de autoridad
no es el momento de consolidación fiscal
en estos momentos hay que proteger a las
personas hay que relanzar la economía
tenemos que tener un crecimiento fuerte
y con este crecimiento fuerte nos
permitirá más adelante cuando ya se haya
acabado la pandemia empezar a consolidar
el gasto ver dónde se puede gastar mejor
donde hay que gastar menos y
probablemente como usted dice hay áreas
como la educación y la sanidad que son
prioritarias y si hay que revisar el
gasto en profundidad y ver dónde hay que
gastar más y dónde hay que gastar menos
durante esta pandemia hemos escuchado
muchas veces que estamos en un punto de
inflexión que este sistema económico hay
que cambiarlo
qué sensación tiene usted que se dice en
los pasillos de la 12 de aquí en la en
la sede en parís hay economistas que
dicen bueno si estamos estamos al final
de
de una época no hay que hacer otras
cosas bueno es un poco difícil saber
cómo vamos a saber todos cómo vamos a
salir de esta pandemia no aunque parece
que va a durar bastante tiempo pero es
cierto que ya vemos que hay cambios que
están sucediendo en la economía el
primero que me viene a la cabeza es el
teletrabajo hemos visto como un montón
de gente ha cambiado al teletrabajo otra
cosa que hemos que hemos visto que ha
cambiado es que hemos empezado a ver
mucha más venta online en las empresas
poco a poco van a tener que mejorar su
presencia online para llegar a más
mercados y luego yo creo que en cuarto
lugar en relación a la pregunta anterior
nos estamos dando cuenta que esta crisis
está teniendo un efecto muy importante
sobre algunos colectivos los
trabajadores que no pueden tener
trabajar las familias más vulnerables
entonces va a ser importante salir de
esta crisis invirtiendo más en educación
invirtiendo más en sanidad y ya para
terminar algún dato esperanzador
en este informe tan de números rojos
bueno yo creo que que hemos aprendido de
otras crisis como decía antes yo creo
que los gobiernos han reaccionado
rápidamente han han utilizado
herramientas que empezaron a utilizar
durante la crisis financiera como por
ejemplo los artes o así se llaman en
españa y eso ha ayudado a que el impacto
haya sido menor
pero yo creo que hay que tomar esta
oportunidad para para generar un
crecimiento más inclusivo más verde hay
que hay que utilizar todo este
financiamiento que viene de los
gobiernos para invertir en en
infraestructuras que sean mejores para
el medio ambiente y para ayudar a las
personas que se queden atrás bueno pues
con este mensaje nos quedamos muchísimas
gracias a ida caldera economista en la
12 d por aclararnos todos estos datos
encantado y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes ya saben que nos pueden seguir
por internet en rf y mundo.com y en
france24 puntocom hasta pronto amigos
[Música]